>> Tucker: BRETT KAVANAUGH SWORN
IN, ENSKONSED IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
THE LEFT ANGER IS NOT CLOSE TO
ENDING.
PRETTY SOON IT WILL BE SO BAD WE
WILL NEED A NEW COMMITTEE TO
INVESTIGATE IT.
TODAY ON "THE VIEW" SOME ONE
IDENTIFIED AS A LEGAL ANALYST
SAID WHEN IT COMES TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT, DUE PROCESS PLAYS NO
ROLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> AFTER 40 YEARS WE FINALLY
CHANGED THE LAW.
WE FINALLY SAID A WOMAN'S WORD
IS FLUFF.
I'VE TAKEN MANY CASES TO TRIAL
WITH JUST A WOMAN'S KWORD.
-- WORD.
>> EVERY SINGLE WOMAN NEEDS TO
BE HEARD.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT WOMEN ARE
CORRECT.
BUT, SONNY, YOU ARE INSINUATING
THAT EVIDENCE DOESN'T MATTER.
AS A LAWYER, EVIDENCE SHOULD
ALWAYS MATTER.
>> IT IS EVIDENCE, TESTIMONY.
YOU DON'T NEED CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE.
YOU DON'T NEED A RAPE KIT.
YOU DON'T NEED WITH ITS BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES THERE'S NO WITH ITS
DURING RAPE.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EVIDENCE, TESTIMONIAL EVIDENC
EVIDENCE --
>> Tucker: ALLEN DERSHOWITZ
SPENT DECADES TEACHING AT
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL, HE KNOWS
ABOUT DUE PROCESS, AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK "THE CASE AGAINST
IMPEACHING TRUMP" AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON, PROFESSOR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU HEARD SPECIFIC
LEGAL CLAIM THAT IT IS NOW THE
LAW IN THE UNITED STATES THAT,
AND I'M QUOTING, A WOMAN'S WORD
IS ENOUGH.
THAT'S IT.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> TECHNICALLY IT IS TRUE, THE
LAW WAS CHANGED SOME YEARS AGO,
AND I THINK IT WAS A GOOD
CHANGE, THAT YOU DON'T NEED
CORROBORATION TO MAKE A CASE.
SO THAT IF A WOMAN, WHO WAS
RAPED, IMMEDIATELY GOES TO THE
HOSPITAL, GETS A RAPE KIT,
IDENTIFIES HER ASSAILANT, KNEW
HER ASSAIL AREN'T, HER WORD
WOULD BE ENOUGH.
IF IT'S 35 YEARS OLD, THE MAIN
WITH IT SAID NO SHE WASN'T
THERE, IF THERE ARE
INCONSISTENCIES IN THE STORY,
OBVIOUSLY, THE TESTIMONY OF THE
WOMAN, THOUGH TECHNICALLY
SUFFICIENT, WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH
TO CONVINCE ANY REASONABLE FACT
FINDER BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT.
THINK OF THE CASE TODAY, HARVEY
WEINSTEIN, I CONSULTED BRIEFLY
ON ONE OF THE E-MAIL ISSUES IN
THAT CASE, HAD THE MAIN
ACCUSERS, ACCUSATION AGAINST HIM
DISMISSED TODAY.
EVIDENCE CAME OUT THAT A
DETECTIVE SUPPRESSED THAT THE
MAIN ACCUSER TOLD A FRIEND THAT
SHE HAD WILLINGLY AND
VOLUNTARILY ENGAGED IN ORAL SEG
WITH HARVEY WEINSTEIN TO BE CAST
IN A ROLE, HAVING PRESUMABLY
TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT HE
FORCED HER TO HAVE SEX.
WOMEN WOULD DIE.
THEY LIE FOR ECONOMIC REASONS.
I AGREE THAT MOST WOMEN TELL THE
TRUTH BUT MOST ISN'T ENOUGH TO
CONVICT SOMEBODY.
YOU NEED PROOF BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
SECRETARY IN THIS CASELY SONNY
IS A GOOD LAWYER, SHE IS
CORRECT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE ELEMENTS THAT
CAST DOUBT ON THE WORD OF THE
WOMAN, THEN CORROBORATION
CERTAINLY HELPS STRENGTHEN THE
CASE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DOUBT A WOMANED WORD, THAT'S
STILL LEGAL.
IS THIS A SEX-SELECTIVE
QUESTION?
IS IT DO WE BELIEVE WOMEN MORE
THAN WE BELIEVE MEN?
>> FIRST OF ALL NOT ONLY ARE YOU
ALLOWED, BUT IF YOU'RE ON A JURY
YOU ARE OBLIGED TO PRESUME THE
INNOCENCE OF THE DEFENDANT WHICH
MEANS YOU CANNOT PRESUME THAT
THE WITNESS IS TELLING THE
TRUTH.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE TOTALITY
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
LOOK, WE KNOW, WE'VE SEEN CASE
AFTER CASE WHERE WOMEN HAVE TOLD
THE TRUTH, AND HAVE BEEN
ASSAULTED, AND MEN HAVE GOTTEN
AWAY WITH IT.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN CASE AFTER CASE
WHERE WOMEN FOR THEIR OWN
REASONS LIED, THE VIRGINIA CASE,
THE CASE -- OTHER CASES.
CASE AFTER CASE.
AND SO, WE DON'T START WITH THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THERE'S A
GENETICALLY LINKED
CHARACTERISTIC --
>> Tucker: OH, GOOD, WE WERE
GETTING PRETTY -- YOU WERE